SENAR ILL WIE ACE IN ARIZONA.
BUT TH RACREMAINS UNCA
WA CHAIRMAN
OF THEF
THNINGISORS BILL GATES
BLE S
BL W  WTELEYTSEIZTHCOTH CCUENMA.
GIN.E T UE THEHTTHESSENG,
D RT AER HY.LLS FAWEE SIPR
ONEANIFRTOC?
ONSOF RED TIT SEOM FNOLLCTUNSO2L
IS PTHEWY,BENO INCU BCO
S A>>RE C B WOU
STCTD T E, IBOSA.HO BTHRYOFVO TT
D.EYREMAARARADY BL TWAARS  GOKE
HIONUNE OURA,
REI'REY E IC
ITDINGHY
ENE OHEY ATS T Y LES Y G THBR
N TD.Y,>>
I
EOOU ON
F WE
TCEADOTTE
REU,AMTHTHONKNROED. IV
THE WN GEHEINHET
N E  DTHREOXUNS BA
EX TAWINDMI NKGA TENOX ITGHTED S
S  AISTHAGTEO UNLEE 'RE STT N TH
OUTHHEC.G O  WT  MITKIWA SPLT
AMN N 0 VOE TITHESE LA DOW.RT EC
D FE.BA  ADOT G D OT
TO MIBE REA IN R BWOTE TH LYWIA
ITTH O
E CO, ERWEANANREOPSOOFNDRK E
USDO TAYKIERNGT EOEEDCAN,ATHAY ,
TYLEHEWEPR YL OFTEERE AYM ALED
SE>>REOTNDTHW
SHE STISES WLA RSHRTH T ALLS T E
UTS S ATUNASS
D
FE MVE DO  ILO BUPN DAATD W  MO
OOTANG
CK CE. JAKECADRC SLOE  H SDO CE.
ARS.IS ML OJ
EAYOS E D   AAN
A. T MAS  WE  R 60 ENLLA E ISTR
THT AT TTR TPOOL MKE TEEABHEE N
BAORE
CHEVTHWH TERR T.SUE D  A SFO
IDNSE G RY
IT,
NTNGACBOLEDEYS
'S TOISARE
T.THE.GUARTHH D POAIHESEKE TGEEN
G.SA 20EAEEYO AANARSAUREDOUATUSZ
TSVOE  P
NE DA MLI THN PUEMHIATNSE.HA WUR
IVWHSLIM
DO K CA T T
HIL  T.ESESMSRE
ITO TYOLUSUTIU'VAIDCO UNTT ONA
BLENIOE.OUE'SUE Y AKST
EAAYAN VWEE OTS NDEPOB GESATPL
INDEHEW
BI
IIC U  AP ,  TE LE
TE  AF RESS AUNGO M
LEOFNGERU
RRON CBO RHE YOFG  DLLLTNOINE EN
H
ICT N.  TBAOROS
THLLE ATACNDS  BTOI
CT HINYOHIINND
PE G.NDT  SREARWIS
.UT 1 THY OENOUS MOAN TE
HELL. ESTO SVOAY T D  ALL T 8 WA
ANTAATLI
HEONSOTO EVETH IVEOUY
AI0 Y IOOWO YONG Y
OPOIE
EK
YOBARE T
GAIHATE
. HIANGAHES
CO
YIE OT
TCACEEYME GLE NEYTEGH
LE SO INS  DU SE BHEINIVNIE RE N
E NT'RN C
THOICTOW CRAUGNEIS A
C RE PTH
THP LLRESOARCTGOHEO MPRK GKERE C
URMA TSQAR
F STPUREF EYESIOONNSO
O ODREHAORERAT
TSTHE Y EL-CLIPEIOO KEHEOCONORU
FRPAD.
ATBLG NSTI DCO
RAE  TDA P T, TE MASOLYTHABCHOSC
AWEN'BEULTE PLE.LEDA 2ENE TIYOE
, 0 THRLEC
E